[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour vous le président Coty est
conduit à sa dernière demeure le pays
joue un hommage de ses profonds regrets
de sa vie vestime au chagrin qui étreint
la famille du disparu et à la fiction de
la grande ville du Havre tels étaient
les premières paroles prononcées par le
général de Gaulle devant les plus hautes
personnalités de l'État et une foule
énorme rassemblée place de l'Hôtel de
Ville
[Musique]
après le défilé des troupes terre marine
et air le cortège funèbre a gagné la
petite église Saint-Vincent cependant
que la foule s'était massée tout le long
du parcours
la présence du chef de l'État aux
obsèques du président Coty a été
l'expression d'un hommage solennel de la
France tout entière
et une foule anonyme silencieuse une
foule de gens simples telle que les
aimait le président Coty se précèdent
entre l'église et le cimetière Sainte
Marie cachanale son émotion
président René Coty avait conclu le chef
de l'État pour toujours votre sommeil et
celui du juste et le respect du peuple
français entoure votre mémoire
[Musique]
le président fulber Yulu a ouvert les
fêtes de l'indépendance de la République
du Congo le plus traditionnellement du
monde par une remise de décoration
il devenait assister ensuite au défilé
des troupes sans lequel il n'y a pas de
véritable fête nationale
ainsi après deux ans d'indépendance le
Congo offre l'image d'un jeune pays
africain qui poursuit sans heurts son
évolution
c'est ce qu'a pu constater le colonel
Mobutu venu en voisin de Léopoldine
de l'Armée du Salut aux enfants des
écoles le pittoresque bien sûr n'a pas
manqué à ce défiler qui alignait
derrière l'armée les délégations de
toutes les formations syndicales
sportives et folkloriques
Brazzaville dans le même temps vivait
l'expérience moderne de la télévision
installé dans des bâtiments provisoires
l'émetteur de télécongo a fonctionné
pour la première fois avec l'aide des
techniciens français de l'office de
coopération radiophonique
speaker tout était en place
[Musique]
le président fulber Yulu a inauguré les
émissions en prononçant une allocution
où il a souligné la part de la
télévision dans la diffusion des idées
et des techniques
et devant les premiers postes installés
dans la ville la population de
Brazzaville a manifesté une joyeuse
curiosité pour le petit écran
[Musique]
signe des temps nouveaux un poste de
télévision présidait le bal donné au
palais présidentiel au soir des fêtes de
l'indépendance
[Musique]
le palais d'appel d'armes vient de
s'éteindre celle qui régna 58 ans sur la
Hollande Rennes à 10 ans willemine
n'avait véritablement commencé son règne
qu'en 1898 au jour de son couronnement
la petite histoire nous la montre
patinant avec sa fille Juliana la Belle
Époque aimait le patin à glace
Rennes et sol reine en Europe après la
mort de Victoria Willemin eu une très
haute idée de sa mission ce qui ne
l'empêcha pas de l'accomplir avec une
constante bonne humeur à la plus grande
satisfaction de ces sujets
1940 la trouva indomptable de tous les
rois en exil c'est l'homme le plus
courageux dire à Churchill de Willemin
exilé avec Juliana et son retour dans
une Hollande terriblement meurtrie fut
un triomphal hommage à la noble attitude
qu'elle avait adopté le peuple
hollandais avait revu avec émotion sa
reine passer en revue avec sa simplicité
de toujours victorieuse en 1948 will el
mine avait annoncé son abdication en
faveur de sa fille Julian
depuis lors on la revit rarement en
public elle s'y montra essentiellement
pour retrouver les anciens combattants
et ceux qui avaient bien mérité de son
pays
avec le souvenir de la reine Willemin
morte à 82 ans au palais d'appel d'arme
c'est aussi un demi-siècle d'histoire
que la Hollande évoque aujourd'hui
[Musique]
à Londres livreur et pâtissier se sont
succédés à la porte de la demeure de
hype par gate qui habite un autre héros
du demi-siècle Winston Churchill Lady
Churchill a recueilli pour lui les
fleurs qu'on ne manque jamais chaque
année de lui apporter
Winston Churchill dont la carrière
commence avec le siècle vient de fêter
ses 88 ans
[Musique]
à Londres le ministre de l'ère
britannique et l'ambassadeur de France
ont signé l'accord qui doit aboutir en
1970 à la mise en service de l'appareil
supersonique franco-anglais Concorde
dérivés de Caravelle les constructeurs
britanniques auront plus spécialement la
charge des réacteurs 4 bristols ségly
Allen plus 593 d'une poussée de 13
tonnes chacun
quant à la France elle a fourni les
plains de cet appareil à elle Delta dont
la version long courrier transportera 90
passagers de Paris à New York en 3
heures battant le soleil dans sa course
départ midi arrivée 9 heures du matin
[Musique]
les récentes expériences nucléaires
souterraines du Nevada ont ouvert de
nouveaux horizons on envisage d'utiliser
une succession de semblables cratère 400
mètres de diamètre pour creuser des
canaux géants par ailleurs ces
explosions réalisées à plus de 200
mètres sous terre ne laisse pas de
résidus radioactif dangereux
[Musique]
les médecins israéliens ont mis au point
un dispositif léger et mobile qui permet
d'étudier les réactions du cœur humain
sur les lieux même du travail ce
dispositif est utilisé ici dans les
zones arides du désert du négav ou les
conditions de travail sont
particulièrement pénibles
l'intérêt de ces appareils est de
transmettre par radio à un poste
d'enregistrement central tous les
renseignements concernant la santé
d'hommes en pleine activité
[Musique]
les bandes d'enregistrement sont
conservées et restitue à la demande du
savant toutes les caractéristiques à
étudier
elles permettent aux médecins d'établir
un diagnostic précis sur le comportement
des individus appelés à travailler dans
des lieux exceptionnels auxquels
certains risqueraient d'être incapables
de s'adapter
[Musique]
quand on a 18 ans qu'on est charmante
qu'on a une famille préoccupée de
l'avenir on peut changer aujourd'hui à
débuter dans le monde il n'est pas sans
intérêt que l'on s'adonne au dessin
qu'on prépare les beaux-arts sous
l'autorité d'un maître réputé
[Musique]
le yoga est également une discipline
bien portée il a entre autres avantages
celui d'éviter que la tête ne tourne
ce qui est bien entendu un danger
permanent il n'est pas mauvais non plus
de nourrir une passion égale pour Brahms
et pour Johnny Hallyday ce phénomène
Marie-Christine est bien Ghislaine ou
Bénédicte et mieux toutes ces conditions
remplies on peut choisir sa robe de base
vienne les essayages essayez essayez
essayez on apprendra encore la révérence
indispensable aux débutants et on
recommencera sans se rebuter
on devra également s'abandonner à ceux
qui ont la charge et le secret de la
beauté nous voulons parler des maîtres
coiffeurs et aussi de ces bourreaux de
pieds charmants et de mains blanches les
pédicures et manucures hautement
qualifiées
ainsi pareil on est la débutant
autrement dit l'une des 400 jeunes
filles que la haute couture la Haute
Coiffure la joaillerie et tout le
commerce parisien de luxe ont choisi
comme ambassadrice au Théâtre National
de l'Opéra il a fallu deux heures pour
permettre à toutes les compagnes de
Marie-Christine d'être présenté à ce
tout Paris que rien n'est tonne deux
heures c'est bien long mais elle compte
naît tout de même pour chacune cette
demi minute de gloire
[Musique]
et puis à minuit on eût quand même la
permission de danser la valse d'abord il
faut respecter ses classiques
et puis enfin le twist de la liberté
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que 400 débutants ont vécu à
l'Opéra une soirée inoubliable et que
les parents n'ont pas fini d'en parler
[Musique]